What about rotation?
So here,
I'm basically showing a simple example.
I have two points, x and, this would
be the original points here, and
x prime, y prime, where I want
the transformation to happen.
Of course, in this case,
these two vectors kind of show how the
transformation would be, and of course,
there would be an angle
associated with this.
Let's call that theta.
So in case now,
just looking at the simple 2D example,
let me ask the question.
So in this case of the simple
2D rotation by a theta,
where I have transformed points x and
y to x prime, y prime.
Question comes up is, how would I now
figure out the values of x prime,
y prime, given x and
y and this angle theta?
Now, if you may remember this from
your old trigonometry classes,
this can be done, and I encourage you
to look it up again if you haven't,
looked at such things recently.
And this would basically say that x
prime would basically be computed by
taking the cosine of the angle
theta here, with x the original x,
minus y sine theta.
And similarly y prime would be given
by x sine theta plus y sine theta.
So this basically now gives us an input,
interesting way.
Now of course I can write
this in a matrix form,
which basically would
mean I would move x and
y into a column, which would now give
me the elements of the M matrix.
So M in this case would be cosine
theta minus sine theta, sine theta,
cosine theta.
And if of course,
knowing this angle I can apply
this as an image transformation.
Again, I encourage you to look this up
or try to kind of do the derivation.
Just as a hint, to do this derivation,
you'd also need to
represent this angle and
then basically come up with equations
to kind of compare all of these.